In the context of data science,
when creating visualizations, you should almost always focus on
communicating in the most effective manner to solve the problems at hand.
Although data artists, or even a data journalist,
may be interested in creating a complex graphic to creatively convey
information, data scientists' first priority is solving problems.
Whether that be through models, algorithms, analyses, or visualizations.
When faced with a dataset that you want to visualize, you should inspect your
data, the columns, the variables, inspect what types they are, and always
choose the right tool, in this case chart, that best represents your data.
We will see in just a second all the options and how to determine which chart
might be best for representing our given data and conveying a certain message.